still a little bitter if you have been
talking about different kinds of series
and sequences right I'm sort of gonna
get off on off on a bit of a tangent and
there's nothing doing circles we're
going to do gp's next lesson but first
if I can remind you and we said there
are three ways to define a series or
sequence to remember that three ways we
said firstly you can just name a few
terms right so you just name them right
second way goes the second way you could
have an algebraic expression that told
you what the nth term was okay so these
two are equivalent they're just
different ways of saying anything and
lastly we said there was that um that
we've won the recursive definition right
which meant that you said when you stop
it's a finite starting point and then
define a rule that'll tell you where to
go from there
okay so for instance if I started to I
can get all the rest of the even numbers
by saying the nth term is the previous
term plus 2 right
for ends rather than one so one two
three definitions now see mine
annotation relates to this middle one
it takes that expression for each intern
and says what I can I can define a
certain part of a sequence or series
series actually with these certain
connotations his I worked on Sigma as
you know it's Greek letter right okay so
if we use the capital in up it looks
like this we use it because it's it's
stands about you know s it's the Greek
letter S so it's taking the sum so in
some ways it's a little bit like the the
integral notation you know when we use
the UM the strip's down s which men take
the sum of and then you define the
integral so see meditations going to do
the same thing but it's gonna do with
this okay it's going to do with this
second definition so for instance if I
want to try
what'll I screw up let's take the even
numbers okay if I wanted to say take
some on the first 10 even numbers just
write that what I could write the first
10 numbers out or I could use Sigma
notation which is kind of a shorthand so
it would look like this you'd say see ma
and before I go any further by the way
um some people will write Sigma like
this okay and they're in a hurry I can
sort of see the resemblance all right
but uh yeah a little part of my soul
dies every time someone writes a secret
like that so please do it properly
um Sigma and then you need to find what
each term is like so the even numbers a
defined moment too many now that's the
some of the even numbers but if I want
the first ten okay I'll have to find a
stop point and an end point so I'll say
I'll start down here N equals one so
this is remember our on integral
notation right if I say in print from A
to B we call these bounds right so you
got a lower bound your starting point
and an upper bound where you end this is
gonna be very very soon so N equals one
will be on first turn follow up the
first ten I'll end the tenth one I'll
just put a 10 up there okay I mean
strictly speaking I could say N equals
10 that's where I want to finish but
because it's always gonna be the same we
just put attempt is that okay all right
so if I were to actually write that out
okay so that's actually what it means
right because it's this is what each
term is and and so it progresses from
one to ten of course we don't have to
start at N equals one I could have
started at ten and ended 20 or something
like that by the way what's it equal to
it's a it's an arithmetic series right
so I'll take my first and my last term's
which is after 22 and then a parable of
how many pairs do I have I've got five
years so I guess five by 22 so that's
yeah anyway that was just a minor
generic so that's that Sigma notation
okay so sometimes you'll get given the
Sigma notation and asked to evaluate
which is this is one of people class
alternatively you'll get this and be
asked to go back to the Sigma notation
okay did that make sense so it's not
that complicated like I said it's very
similar to in two rules but when people
see it for the first time they just kind
of freak out because it looks like I
scare them that's all